hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and as you could tell by the title
there is a new Christmas event happening
very soon there was a trailer released
on Ubisoft's YouTube channel and it
showed a lot of the details of what's
going to be going on in this new winter
event so let's get right into that so
real quick I do have to apologize for my
voice if you were in the stream you
noticed that I was a bit sick so I do
apologize but regardless this event is
going to be called the frost wind
festival it's going to be going on from
December 21st to January 4th and it's
going to be the new Christmas event for
for honor now judging from the trailer
it's going to be coming with a new game
mode called ice brawler's which will
introduce a new setting for the 2v2
brawl matches the surface of a frozen
lake where the thin ice begins to crack
as the match wears on creating deadly
hazards for careless heroes now most of
you might be familiar with this but a
while ago there was a bug where we got
to actually test this map out before it
was released called Gran's guard it was
not supposed to be in the game it was
supposed to be released when this comes
out but there was a fit there was a bug
and we got to see it through a glitch
you can look in the top right you can
click the eye and you can go to that
Grands guard video that I made to get
caught up if you have no clue what I'm
talking about it'll definitely fill you
in for what the map is about
but regardless judging from the trailer
it seems like there's going to be new
effects a new type of mask like we had
in the last update with the spooky mask
there's going to be some type of dragon
ice mask so I'm really very excited for
this update this looks really cool
really crazy I'm definitely like in the
winter feel as for new executions and
all that other stuff
who knows that'll probably be talked
about maybe in this upcoming dev stream
because today is the 18th and it is
Monday so I believe the 21st is going to
be Thursday so that's going to be the
day of the dev stream so there's gonna
be tons more news probably about this
but the weekly content what it's going
to be and all that other good stuff but
once again I will fill you all in once I
get that information and that's really
about it once again there wasn't
anything crazy it was just a minute and
a half trailer with some teases once
again we're going to be getting a lot
more information coming this Thursday in
the next following weeks of the dev
stream once this update is live and I
once again will keep you all updated on
that with that guys i hope you did enjoy
this very short and very nice and
informational video and if you did
please be sure to give it a like it
really does help me out subscribe if
you're new I cover all the new
the lease the discussion all that good
stuff the informational side of for
honor and while you're at it hit the
bell right next to it so you could stay
notified of all my videos and streams in
my community posts you never miss
anything of mine but two most recent
videos gonna be popping up on screen and
the trailer is going to be linked in the
description if you do want to watch the
full trailer and with that guys I hope
you have a great rest of your day and
peace out